[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg ein herzliches Willkommen
in allen Kristin otto ist auch dabei für
den Sport und mit einer Überraschung
guten Abend wir haben heute unter
anderem diese Themen für Sie
schwere Explosion auf der krimbrücke die
für russlandstrategisch wichtige
Verbindung aufs Festland wird dabei
stark beschädigt
Sabotage Angriff auf die Bahn tausende
stranden im Norden Deutschlands weil
unbekannte mehrere Kabel zerstören
und Nerven stark ins WM-Finale auch ohne
die Top-Stars besiegt das deutsche
tischtennis-team Südkorea und trifft auf
die Favoriten aus China
[Musik]
die Brücke zur Krim ist ein
Prestigeprojekt Russlands jetzt ist sie
teilweise zerstört durch eine Autobombe
sagt Moskau drei Menschen seien dabei
ums Leben gekommen der Kreml hatte immer
wieder gewarnt ein Anschlag auf diese
Brücke würde eine rote Linie klar
überschreiten
so sah die Straßen und Eisenbahnbrücke
vor der Explosion aus mit 19 km eine der
längsten Brücken Europas sie liegt in
der Meerenge zwischen dem schwarzen und
dem Asowschen Meer und verbindet die von
Russland annektierte Halbinsel Krim mit
dem russischen Festland Thomas Gonsior
berichtet
Momente vor der Explosion gefilmt von
einer Überwachungskamera dann ein
Feuerstoß die Flammen die Druckwelle sie
erfassen die Fahrbahn die stürzt ins
Meer
auch auf einen Zug breitet sich das
Feuer aus auf der parallel verlaufenden
Bahnstrecke mehrere Waggons sollen
Treibstoff geladen haben Moskau sperrt
die Brücke erst beschränkt am Abend den
Verkehr setzt Ermittler ein
nach vorläufigen Erkenntnissen
explodierte ein LKW er kam von der
russischen Halbinsel Taman ein Unfall
ein Anschlag und wenn wer steckt
dahinter all das noch unklar klar ist
nur die Beschädigung der Brücke ist ein
Schlag für Russland und die Krim
praktisch militärisch heißt es dass die
Versorgung der Krim damit erschwert wird
und das auch die Versorgung der
russischen Truppen in der Ukraine
erschwert würden denn der krimflughafen
zimperopolis geschlossen Nachschub
gibt’s abgesehen von Seewegen nun wohl
verstärkt über den Umweg militopol
gefährlicher weil im Kampfgebiet
aus symbolisch ist die Brücke wichtig
2018 weite Kreml Chef Putin sie ein per
lkw-konvoi der Diktator als Truckfahrer
er zeigte die Krim sei angebunden sei
russisch der Anschlag jetzt hat eine
andere Botschaft
Russland ist verwundbar Russland ist
nicht in der Lage die annektierten
Gebiete zu sichern und zu kontrollieren
entsprechend groß nun der Fahndungsdruck
in sozialen Netzwerken kursiert dieses
Bild angeblich der explodierte LKW bei
einer Kontrolle Moskau sagt man ermittle
mit Hochdruck es geht um viel für
Russland
fragen wir Katrin Eigendorf in harkev
wer könnte für diesen Anschlag
verantwortlich sein
es gibt da sehr viele Spekulationen und
was interessant in Rahmen all dieser
Spekulationen es ist sie Tatsache dass
die denen das am meisten nützt nämlich
die Ukraine sich nicht klar zu diesem
Anschlag bekennen aber in maximalen
nutzen um noch mal ihre Strategie zu
verkünden da heißt es zum Beispiel aus
Kreisen der Regierung das sei wieder
einmal ein Zeichen dafür dass die
Ukraine nicht anerkennen wird dass ihre
Staatsgebiete annektiert werden dass
alles zurückerobert wird oder von Seiten
des ukrainischen Militärs heißt es das
sah ein großer Vorteil denn damit würde
Russland weiter Nachschub abgeschnitten
und würde es vor allem im Süden und
schwieriger werden dem ukrainischen
Vorstoß standzuhalten das ist ganz
interessant und der Berater des des
ukrainischen Präsidenten selenski hat
noch mal eine ganz neue Variante heute
geäußert er hat gesagt dass es im
Prinzip die Russen sind die zu diesem
Anschlag stecken das nämlich im Prinzip
ist hier um ein Machtkampf geht wo die
russischen Militärs dem Geheimdienst
zeigen wollen dass er nicht vernünftig
arbeitet und damit dem Geheimdienst
schaden wollen dass es sich hier also um
einen innerrussischen Machtkampf handelt
der hier zu dieser Explosion geführt hat
vielen Dank für diese Einschätzung
Katrin Eigendorf aus rakkev als Reaktion
auf den russischen Angriffskrieg zeigt
die NATO mehr Präsenz in ihren östlichen
Mitgliedsländern und da ist auch
Deutschland gefordert in Litauen für die
Bundeswehr jetzt eine nato-kampfbrigade
an 250 deutsche Soldaten nehmen gerade
am Stützpunkt rukla an einer Übung teil
und bekamen heute Besuch von
bundesverteidigungsministerin Lambrecht
Andrea Maurer berichtet
fast Griffin heißt dass Manöver bei dem
die neue deutsche Kampftruppen Brigade
mit litauischen Truppen an der
nato-ostflanke übt seit 2017 führt
Deutschland ein nato-bataillon in
Litauen jetzt kommen Verstärkungskräfte
dazu heute offiziell in Dienst gestellt
in Anwesenheit der deutschen
Verteidigungsministerin eine
kampftruppenbrigade stärkt in Zukunft im
Rahmen der NATO unseren Beitrag zur
Verteidigung Litauens und der
nato-ostflanke insgesamt die
Panzergrenadierbrigade 41 kann innerhalb
kürzester Zeit hier in Litauen
eingesetzt werden am Morgen war
Christine Lambrecht in Vilnius mit
militärischen ehrenempfangen worden bei
den politischen Gesprächen gleich
mehrere litauische Regierungsmitglieder
am Tisch litauen hat seit dem russischen
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine auf mehr
deutsches Engagement an der
nato-ostflanke gedrängt
heute zweifelt keiner mehr an der von
Russland ausgehenden Bedrohung das ist
eine unmittelbare und langfristige
Bedrohung also ist die Verstärkung der
nato-truppenpräsenz sehr bedeutend der
Führungsstab der Brigade wird fest auf
dem Militärstützpunkt in
ruklastationiert der größte Teil der
Soldaten aber wird in Deutschland
bereitgehalten und soll bei verschärfter
Bedrohungslage innerhalb von zehn Tagen
nach Litauen verlegt werden können hier
in Ruckler ist die Bundeswehr nur wenige
Kilometer von der belarussischen Grenze
entfernt die Übung des deutschen und des
litauischen Militärs die hier bis Mitte
Oktober stattfindet soll Stärke
demonstrieren an der nato-ostflanke die
Botschaft ist klar das bündnisgebiet
wird im Ernstfall verteidigt zu den
Soldatinnen und Soldaten hat die
Ministerin heute gesagt die Sicherheit
Litauens ist die Sicherheit Deutschlands
auch mehr als drei Wochen nach dem Tod
der 22-jährigen Martha Armin nicht gehen
im Iran die Unruhen weiter landesweit
protestieren vor allem junge Menschen
gegen die wie Sie es nennen islamische
Politelite in Irans Hauptstadt Teheran
kam es dabei erneut zu schweren
Ausschreitungen laut der
Menschenrechtsorganisation Iran Human
Rights kommen regelmäßig demonstrierende
ums Leben
nach Deutschland ausgerechnet zum
Wochenende saßen viele Bahnreisende
heute Vormittag fest nahezu der gesamte
Zugverkehr in Norddeutschland viel
Überstunden aus betroffen waren vor
allem die Bundesländer Niedersachsen
Bremen Hamburg und Schleswig-Holstein
auch Fernzüge zwischen Berlin und
Nordrhein-Westfalen waren Überstunden
blockiert die Ursache war Sabotage sagt
die Bundespolizei Hannah Hebestreit
kleine Ursache mit großer Wirkung zwei
gekappte Kabel in Berlin
Hohenschönhausen und Herne haben am
Morgen in Norddeutschland vielen tausend
Menschen die Reise mit dem Zug verdorben
gut drei Stunden lang hatte die Bahn
alle Signale auf halt gestellt weil es
auf dem Strecken keine
Kommunikationsverbindung mehr gab für
Eisenbahner und Reisende hieß es erstmal
kein Anschluss ja die Lage ist ernst
würde ich sagen also wir warten schon
sehr lange wir werden nach München
gefahren ist alles ausgebucht wir wissen
nicht wie wir jetzt wegkommen was mit
unseren Tickets ist wir wollen ja im ICE
jetzt nach Dortmund der fährt ja jetzt
leider nicht und da wollten wir uns
heute Dortmund gegen Bayern uns heute
angucken deswegen wären sich die
Gestrandeten um ihr Fortkommen bemühten
suchte die Bahn nach einer Erklärung für
die Panne und wurde fündig der
Bundesverkehrsminister mit ersten
Ergebnissen es handelt sich hier
eindeutig um vorsätzliche und gezielte
sabotagehandlungen
über die Hintergründe kann man heute nur
spekulieren die Bundespolizei hat die
Ermittlungen aufgenommen auch wenn ab
dem späten Vormittag erste Züge wieder
rollten wird es noch lange dauern bis
sich die Staus auf den Bahnsteigen
aufgelöst haben deutlich länger noch
dürfte die Suche nach den Tätern dauern
die offenbar mit großer Fach und
Ortskenntnis gleich zwei unabhängige
Kommunikationssysteme der Bahn zerstört
haben die Schäden an den Kabeln konnten
Techniker beheben die Hintergründe des
Anschlags auf die Bahn sind noch völlig
unklar
Deutschland steckt in der Krise die
ampelregierung versucht gegenzusteuern
die Verunsicherung ist groß das prägt
auch die Landtagswahl morgen in
Niedersachsen das letzte Bundesland mit
einer großen Koalition nach Umfragen
liegt SPD Ministerpräsident weil zwar
vorn doch über ein Drittel der
Wahlberechtigten ist noch unentschlossen
Elisabeth Schmidt
Unterstützung vom derzeit wohl
prominentesten Niedersachsen Kanzler
Scholz in Osnabrück geboren heute beim
Wahlkampfabschluss der SPD in Hannover
Stefan weil will zum dritten Mal
Ministerpräsident werden Energie und
Preiskrise die Herausforderungen sind
groß ich habe noch keinen Wahlkampf
erlebt wo in den Gesichtern der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger so viele
Fragezeichen standen wo so viele Sorgen
zum Ausdruck gebracht worden sind umso
dankbar bin ich dafür dass gerade in den
letzten Tagen der Zuspruch immer
spürbarer wird an den Wahlkampfständen
dominieren bundespolitische Themen
Wirtschaftsminister Bernd Althusmann CDU
will auf den letzten Metern weil noch
überholen die Politik des
Ministerpräsidenten sei Teil des
chaotischen krisenkurses der
Bundesregierung
wenn Niedersachsen am Ende eine starke
CDU hat die eine Regierung stellen wird
dann ist das auch ein klares Signal in
Richtung Berlin ich denke das könnte
sogar das Ende der Ampel einleiten die
Grünen bislang Oppositionen in
Niedersachsen wollen diesmal oben
mitreden Spitzen Duo Julia Willi Hamburg
und Christian Meyer mussten einige
Kritik am grünen
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Habeck
ausbügeln liegen aber weiter auf Platz 3
wir leben auch erleben auch an den
Ständen sehr viel Zuspruch gerade in der
Frage Herr Habeck hat Fehler gemacht
aber er gesteht sie auch ein und er
korrigiert sie wieder insofern kommt der
grüne Politikstil an selfies wie mit
einem Popstar ob der Auftritt von
fdp-bundeschef Lindner genug Strahlkraft
hat um Spitzenkandidat Stephan Bürkner
über die fünf Prozent Hürde zu helfen
wird sich zeigen er bleibt aber
optimistisch
nein das wird nach meiner Einschätzung
nicht eng ich sehe das so dass wir
sicher im Landtag sein werden und sicher
eben vertreten sein werden die Frage ist
eher ob es eine Regierungsbeteiligung
reicht die AFD mit Spitzenkandidat
stefan marzischewski konnte die
Krisenstimmung im Land zuletzt für sich
nutzen doch es kriselt auch intern der
Verfassungsschutz stufte die Partei im
Juni als Verdachtsfall ein und gegen den
Vize Landeschef wird wegen des Verdachts
der Untreue ermittelt
wenn das stimmt Zuwachs erklären wir uns
weil unsere Themen jetzt bei der
Bevölkerung angekommen sind weil wir
auch erwachsen geworden sind weil wir
tatsächlich Lösungsvorschläge haben
nicht wie uns immer vorgeworfen dass wir
nur meckern gut sechs Millionen Menschen
haben morgen in Niedersachsen die Wahl
und im ZDF Wahlstudio in Hannover läuft
sich Bettina Schausten schon mal warm
welche bundespolitische Bedeutung hat
diese wahlbetina taugt sie als
Stimmungstest für den Bund
also da würde ich sagen nur bedingt was
aber richtig ist und auch untypisch für
eine Landtagswahl das hier in
Niedersachsen weniger die klassischen
landesthemen wie Schule oder Bildung im
Vordergrund stehen sondern die aktuellen
bundesweiten krisenthemen
Energiesicherheit Preise Inflation und
so versucht es die CDU hier auf den
letzten Metern noch mal mit Attacke
gegen die Bundesregierung gegen die
Berliner Ampel unter Olaf Scholz aber
fraglich ob das verfängt dafür ist
spd-ministerpräsident Stefan weil hier
ein zu beliebter Landesvater mit großem
Amtsbonus und es sieht so aus dass er
morgen die Nase vorn haben wird
politisch stehen die Zeichen hier auf
rot-grün wenn die Grünen werden wohl
kräftig zulegen während die FDP zittern
muss ob sie überhaupt im Landtag bleibt
diskussionsstoffe Berlin ist all das in
jedem Fall auch die erwarteten Zugewinne
für die AFD die vom allgemeinen
krisengefühl profitieren wir melden uns
morgen ab 17 Uhr hier aus dem ZDF
Wahlstudio in Hannover bis dahin
Dankeschön nach Hannover und bis morgen
Bettina Schausten war das
in Berlin folgten heute rund 8000
Menschen dem Aufruf der AFD gegen die
Politik der Bundesregierung zu
demonstrieren das Motto der
Veranstaltung
Energiesicherheit und Schutz vor
Inflation unser Land zuerst an mehreren
Stellen gab es Gegendemonstrationen die
Organisatoren werfen der AFD vor die
steigenden Kosten für Lebensmittel und
Energie für ihre Zwecke
instrumentalisieren zu wollen
die steigenden Preise treiben die
Menschen auf die Straße mehr als 160
Organisationen hatten heute zu einem
bundesweiten Aktionstag aufgerufen für
bezahlbaren Wohnraum denn viele können
sich Ihre Miete kaum noch leisten Simone
Friedrich hat mehr
hier in Darmstadt wohnt Familie Russo
fünf Personen in drei Zimmern auf knapp
80 Quadratmetern erst vor kurzem kam
wieder eine Mieterhöhung auf 1040 Euro
monatlich warm 60 Euro mehr jeden Monat
zu bezahlen das ist sehr viel für mich
und wenn ich überlege dass
mein Nettolohn nicht ausreicht um die
Mitte zu stemmen das ist das ist doch
schon einfach verrückt dazu kommen die
weiter steigenden Energiekosten die
Russos kommen nur zurecht weil beide
Eltern arbeiten und sich alle
einschränken die Eltern schlafen im
Wohnzimmer und auch für die Kinder
bleibt nur wenig eigener Raum beim
Aktionstag wollten sie die Politik
wachütteln
auf die Barrikaden sind sie heute auch
in Hamburg gegangen wer hier arbeitet
muss auch in Hamburg leben können so der
Appell auf gleich zwei Demos gegen
explodierende Wohnkosten und für bessere
Unterstützung durch die Politik
das ist das Problem mit der Politik dass
die zu lange braucht zu beschließen wo
die Hilfen hin sollen wer wie
unterstützt werden soll da muss es jetzt
schnelle Hilfen geben bevor den Leuten
das Geld ausgeht das Thema Wohnkosten
birgt inzwischen eine Menge sozialen
Sprengstoff in Deutschland
jetzt der Sport da gab es eine große
Überraschung Kristin die deutschen
Tischtennisspieler super mega werde ich
hier sogar sagen also alle staunen denn
ohne Timo Boll und weitere Topspieler
hat das junge Team von Bundestrainer
Jörg Rosskopf bei der Mannschafts-WM in
Chengdu China nun sogar das Endspiel
heraus durch eine beeindruckende
Aufholjagd gegen Südkorea
und es war wieder Benedikt du da der wie
schon tags zuvor gegen Frankreich beim
Stande von 2:2 das entscheidende Match
austragen musste diesmal gegen den
Südkoreaner Angelo gegen den er noch nie
zuvor gewinnen konnte noch
beeindruckender als bei diesem
hochklassigen Matchball kann man ein
Spiel kaum entscheiden der 28-Jährige
aus Bergneustadt führte das deutsche
Team mit den beiden düsseldorfernangu
und Kai stumper ins Finale wo morgen die
oft übermächtigen Chinesen warten
und zur Fußball-Bundesliga 9 Spieltag
und einem gelungenen Trainer Debüt von
chabi Alonso mit Bayer Leverkusen die
Bayer 11 Klasse Schalke mit 4:0 erste
Saison-Sieg für Bochum 3:0 gegen
schwache Frankfurter Mainz Leipzig eins
zu eins ebenso Augsburg Wolfsburg das
Topspiel Dortmund Bayern ausführlich im
Sportstudio gestern unter lag Hoffenheim
Bremen eins zu zwei morgen noch drei
Spiele unter anderem mit dem bisherigen
Spitzen du Union Berlin und SC Freiburg
so kann sich in der oberen
Tabellenhälfte noch einiges verschieben
Aufsteiger Bremen vorläufig mit einem
großen Sprung von 8 hoch auf Platz 4
Hoffenheim und Frankfurt runter auf 6
und 7 am Tabellenende verlässt
Leverkusen den Abstiegsplatz verbessert
sich auf 14 Schalke fällt auf 16 Bochum
bleibt trotz des ersten drei Punkte
Gewinns weiterhin Schlusslicht
und passend zum Prestige Duell in
Dortmund von 23 Uhr an zu Gast dem
Aktuellen Sportstudio ex-bayern-profi
und ZDF wm-experte Sandro Wagner und
direkt im Anschluss Triathlon WM live im
ZDF der Ironman auf Hawaii bei dem die
Männer um den zweimaligen Weltmeister
Patrick lange vor rund einer Stunde
gestartet sind alles auch schon jetzt im
Livestream und der sportstudio.de
mehr als 26.000 Fans im Stadion und zwei
Treffer der Kapitänin Alexandra Popp die
deutschen Fußballerinnen begeisterten in
Dresden beim 2:1 gegen Frankreich
kurz vor der Pause kommt die verdiente
deutsche Führung Alexandra Popp zum 1:0
schon bei der EM hatte sie das Team mit
einem Doppelpack gegen Frankreich ins
Finale befördert auch in Dresden folgt
ein zweiter Treffer 48 Minute das 2:0
das 61 Länderspieltor von Alexandra Popp
in 122 Spiel das 2:1 per Foul Elfmeter
kurz vor Schluss durch Vivian asseli
ändert nicht viel an der Partystimmung
in Dresden ein gelungener Test für die
noch ferne WM im nächsten Jahr in
Australien und Neuseeland
gute Voraussetzungen für Formel 1
Weltmeister Max Verstappen für eine
vorzeitige Titelverteidigung der
Niederländer sicherte sich in seinem Red
Bull für den Großen Preis von Japan in
Suzuka die Poleposition vor den beiden
Ferrari Piloten Schale Claire und Carlos
sankts Start morgen früh um 7 Uhr früh
ja Zeitverschiebung Morgen zeigt sich
der goldene Oktober nur leider nicht
überall wo es sonnig wird und wo er trüb
erzählt gleich Christa Orban Viertel vor
elf freut sich Marietta Slomka auf sie
im heute-journal und wir sind morgen
wieder da ihnen alles Gute und ein
schönes Wochenende noch auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend
farbenfrohe zeigt sich der Herbst nun
und morgen können wir das meist bei
blauem Himmel genießen denn ganz
verbreitet scheint die Sonne zwischen 8
und 11 Stunden nur hier und da machen
uns die Nebelfelder dann doch einen
Strich durch die Rechnung insgesamt
etwas weniger Sonne gibt es an den
Küsten und vor allem an den Alpen also
südlich der Donau da scheint sie teils
nicht einmal zwei Stunden und hier gibt
es auch heute Nacht die dichtesten
Wolken mit Regen der aber in der zweiten
Nachthälfte abzieht ansonsten klart es
verbreitet auf über der Mitte gibt es
dann diesen dichten Nebel und hier gibt
es morgen früh auch richtig kalte
Temperaturen mit leichtem
frostbodenfrost ist auch möglich bei
drei bis null Grad im Norden und im
Süden ist es mit 10 bis 7 Grad etwas
milder morgen Vormittag bleibt dann eben
teils noch der Nebel mit den kühlen
Temperaturen nach Auflösung scheint aber
die Sonne im Osten haben wir ein paar
harmlose Quellwolken die im Norden auch
etwas häufiger sein können mit Abstand
die meisten Wolken die gibt es aber im
Süden meist bleibt es hier jedoch
trocken es ist hier auch am kühlsten nur
14 Grad 19 Grad gibt es am Oberrhein
etwas milder startet dann die neue Woche
am Montag am Dienstag und am Mittwoch
haben wir dann wieder Temperaturen
zwischen 14 und 18 Grad und Wolken und
Nebel lassen die Sonne nicht mehr so
richtig zum Zug kommen tschüss